we begin tonight with this fox news
alert evidence was overwhelming actor
josie smallett has been found guilty on
five of six charges two years after
staging a fake hate crime against
himself now tonight he's guilty of lying
to a police officer about a purported
hate crime he's guilty of lying to the
same police officer about getting
assaulted guilty of making the same fake
claims to a second officer guilty of
repeating these lies yet again to police
several hours later
smilet is now a convicted felon i wonder
if they'll bring up the issue of lying
to a jury under a judge under oath
we'll talk to our legal team in a minute
now remember it all started around 2 a.m
on a freezing cold january night deep
blue chicago when the former empire
actor calls 911 tells police he was
viciously attacked on his way back from
grabbing a subway sandwich jesse then
alleged that two white males trump
supporters wearing red maga hats
targeted him with racial and homophobic
slurs they doused him with an unknown
liquid they beat him up they placed a
noose around his neck when police
arrived to the scene a white rope was
still around his neck but in a matter of
days jesse's story started to fall apart
abc news they still invited jesse on for
a very sympathetic sympathetic interview
with host robin roberts take a look
i'm an advocate
i respect too much
the people
who i am now one of those people
who have been attacked in any way
you do such a disservice when you lie
about things like this
if the attackers are never found
how will you be able to heal
um
i don't know
let's just hope that they are
you know what i'm saying like let's
let's not go there yet
let's talk
i was talking to a friend and i said i
just want them to find them
and she said
sweetie they're not gonna find them
that just made me so angry
such a disservice when you lie like this
as jessie smuller tweeted in 2010 quote
what liars don't realize is that they're
the most obvious people bs isn't that
hard to smell just open your nose and
your breath and by the way hey uh jesse
we found your attackers according to a
massive trove of evidence justice
malette paid two nigerian immigrant
brothers his workout buddies to help
stage this attack both individuals
testified against mollet after police
determined that the brothers purchased
the rope that was used in this fake
attack along with a red hat and gloves
and a check from jesse smallett made out
to one of the brothers was also
recovered we had surveillance footage
showing the trio practicing the attack
the day before jesse called 9-1-1 we
have text messages phone records also
show the trio plotting the fake hate
crime what justice mollet did was vile
but even worse the incredible but
predictable rush to judgment from the
media mob from the hollywood celebrity
mob and from the democratic party mob
jesse smallett claims that in the middle
of chicago on a freezing cold winter
night while out for a subway sandwich at
2 a.m two white trump supporters wearing
maga hats recognized
he really is a d-list actor hunted him
down and attacked him while yelling this
is magga country now it's a pretty
strange far-fetched story but almost
everyone on the left they bought it hook
they bought it line they bought it
sinker joe biden tweeting quote what
happened today to justice millet must
never be tolerated in this country we
must stand up and demand that we no
longer give this hate safe harbor that
homophobia and racism have no place on
our streets in our hearts and we are
with you jesse kamala harris tweeting
jesse smallette is one of the kindest
most gentle human beings i know i'm
praying for his quick recovery this was
an attempted modern day lynching cory
booker also called it a modern day
lynching the reverend al sharpton said
quote the reported hate attack on my
friend and brother actor jesse smallette
is despicable and outrageous the guilt
must face the maximum i guess he didn't
learn from prior incidents in new york
disgraced governor andrew cuomo quote
new york state calls the attack on jesse
smallett what it is a hate crime
congresswoman talib quote when one of
the most famous black and gay men in
america is not safe the message is
clearer than it has ever been the
dangerous lie spewing from the right
wing is killing and hurting our people
and here's an official tweet from the
human rights campaign our thoughts are
with justice millet after this
horrifying attack it's a tragic reminder
that racism and homophobia are still
rampant in the u.s
bernie sanders jumped in called it
racist and a homophobic attack eric
swalwell jumped in said it was vile and
tragic maxine waters announced that she
was dedicated to finding the culprits
stick durbin to cried america's racist
and homophobic ways cher she joined in
she went on an unhinged rant she blamed
president trump katy perry said she was
standing with jesse jameel hill was
disgusted in appall ariana grande grande
tweeted that she was sick to her stomach
joy reid calling it a chilling attack
and on tv the hot takes were just as bad
take a look
you think about what just happened to
jesse smallett in chicago
unfortunately we have racism germinating
from the white house jesse is love
that's who he is
and that's all he knows so
in this situation hate won't win it will
not
we have a media that's saying it's a
debate whether or not which has happened
to jesse small it is a hate crime it's
absurd
this isn't a debate
i agree
a u.s congressman from illinois bobby
rush is calling for an immediate and
sweeping civil rights investigation into
the racist and homophobic attack on
jesse smollett
i don't like that it's being put out
there in the media that this is a
possible hate crime and the media has
really cast so much doubt on his story
which i find so personally offensive and
senator cory booker said the vicious
attack on actor jesse was an attempted
modern day lynching
this is america in 2019.
now why would the media why would
democrats why would people on tv why
would they rush so quickly to judgment
well it just sees far-fetched story fit
their anti-trump narrative didn't it so
they didn't bother to investigate they
didn't take their time they didn't make
phone calls they didn't interview
potential witnesses they didn't wait for
police to reveal any evidence they
didn't care if it was true or not that's
why this same cast of characters same
people in many cases smeared in
slandered kyle rittenhouse kyle's kyle
was labeled the white supremacist by
then presidential candidate joe biden
where's the apology joe kamala harris
called him a vigilante and an extremist
they were wrong then they are wrong now
but don't ever expect a retraction or an
apology three and a half years donald
trump colluded with russia the only one
that colluded with russia and bought a
dirty russian dirty dossier was hillary
clinton and they used that unverified to
spy on a presidential candidate and a
president the left in this country they
don't give a damn about truth or justice
they get it wrong every single time they
don't care if they ruin somebody's life
they will lie they will smear they will
slander they will be smart anyone for
political gain we have enough instances
kyle written house recently remember the
cambridge police acting stupidly a high
school student you might remember his
name nicholas sandman they were wrong in
ferguson missouri you know why we were
right because i actually had people that
were involved in the case my source is
telling me multiple eyewitnesses will
confirm that officer darren wilson's
story that in fact it was michael brown
reaching into his car trying to grab his
gun and then later michael brown
charging at the officer the same thing
in baltimore maryland with freddie gray
uh the same thing with uva remember the
duke lacrosse case we got that right too
why because i actually took the time to
go and drive and meet some of the
families and kids and i knew that they
were building exculpatory evidence that
would ultimately clear them and it did
richard jewell i was on the radio oh he
fits the profile of the lone bomber why
because he lives with his mother i'm on
the air and i'm like just because he
lives with his mother doesn't make him a
domestic terrorist lie smear slander
besmirch repeat rush to judgment repeat
no due process repeat no presumption of
innocence repeat believe any lie any
allegation against somebody that you
politically oppose or will advance your
political agenda jesse smallett carried
out this disgusting hoax likely knowing
that the left would have his back he
knew he knew what would happen he would
become an actual celebrity with instant
fame fortune praise me maybe even a
speaking spot at the dnc
but it fell apart didn't it ultimately
when the facts came in the real tragedy
in all of this investigators had to
spend months and months untangling
jesse's despicable web of lies instead
of solving murders rape and other
violent crime all over the city take a
look right there chicago homicide
victims i've been doing this scroll
since 2009
names of thousands of men women and
children murdered shot in chicago names
you'll never hear from about we'll never
know how many of these people would
still be alive today if police weren't
forced to waste precious time and
resources on
lies like justice millett's lies and
tonight like every night our thoughts
and prayers do stand with these families
the families of real victims names
you'll never hear about the media
ignores because they can't politicize it
jesse presumably cares little about as
well